Speaker 1: Let's get into this week's email
bag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com
if you have a question, comment, suggestion,
correction, whatever.
Really, it's all welcome as long as it's respectful.
Let's get right into the first one.
Linda wrote in about something I said about
the Noah's Ark story last week.
Last week I said, You know what?
I struggle with some of these stories and
fail to get answers when I say, well, if there
were two of every two of every animal, you
had every kind of bird and every kind of insect.
And, you know, we're talking about millions
of species.
How is that possible or what did the carnivorous
animals eat or whatever?
Right.
And Linda wrote in and said, Actually, Linda
and or John, it says both names.
And they say, according to Genesis 129, mankind
and animals were originally vegetarians.
The food was put in the ark.
Pere 622 And in nine one through five, after
they landed, God instituted a new covenant
and the eating of meat.
This is the type of thing that I'm kind of
talking about because there is always some
explanation, but it doesn't actually make
any scientific sense.
So like, for example, in this case, it's well,
the animals were vegetarian at the time of
Noah's Ark, and then the animals started to
eat meat.
Others will say, well, actually, really, God's
will and direction really only applies to
humans, not to animals.
So now, now God is directing what animals
eat.
The other counterpoint would be, Well, if
this all happened in the last five or 6000
years, there is, number one, no evidence that
currently carnivorous animals were ever vegetarian.
And if the idea is they evolved from being
vegetarian to being carnivorous, 5000 years
is not nearly enough time for that to happen
to all of those species.
So that also doesn't make sense.
But I get that they don't believe in the evolution
piece anyway, so it all doesn't make sense.
Another email said, Well, on Noah's Ark, they
were eating pickled and dried meats.
The carnivorous animals ate pickled and dried
meats.
And that's why the the issue of the animals
that were alive being eaten isn't an issue,
but there's no evidence of that.
Another one was they were all eating fish
eggs.
I've not seen any evidence of that.
The other one I got was David.
There were two of each main species, so like
they were just two snakes.
And then later those two snakes became all
the subspecies.
Maybe that would be plausible if we were talking
about millions of years or longer.
But if this all supposedly happened in five
or 6000 years, that doesn't make any sense.
So the point here is they'll always come up
with something, but there's no evidence for
any of the stuff.
And at a certain point, you have to say, well,
what do I accept as evidence?
And I've still not seen any convincing explanation
of the Noah's Ark story.
Okay.
Next is Michael.
Michael wrote in about people who don't talk
politics.
Michael says, there's people on the right
and left, but mainly the right who simply
don't talk politics.
Is there a way to convince them why they need
to get out and vote these radical conservatives
out?
I think many of them are Republicans because
it's passed down.
So, yes, there's lots of people that are Republicans
because they come from a Republican family.
In my experience, the best way to get people
who aren't into politics to follow politics
is to say to them, okay, I get it.
You just you don't care about politics.
You don't care about news.
It's boring.
You're just not interested.
I totally get that.
That makes sense.
There's so many things that that what we can
pay attention to.
Tell me what matters to you.
They go, Well, I don't know.
I like sports and car driving or whatever
else.
No, no, I understand that.
But you must think there's some problems in
the world, either in your immediate community
or with government, or with that there must
be some problem.
And they go, Well, yeah, I mean, I really
hate it that I don't know, whatever.
Write something related to climate or something
related to a law or legislation regulation
of their business.
Where you go, well, you might not care about
politics, but other people then are deciding
how your business is regulated.
Other people are deciding how your immediate
parks that are around you are being taken
care of or not taken care of.
So the point here is people who aren't into
politics usually still have opinions about
the world around them.
And it's about just explaining to them that
it's the political system that will impact
what happens and that that will often work
to get people to say, Oh, I didn't realize
that this thing I care about actually is politics
and I should be paying attention and I should
be involved.
Give it a shot.
Let me know how it works.
Rosen wrote in saying about Clarence Thomas.
David, Sir, whatever happened to the Ginni
Thomas story?
The media seems to have lost interest in it.
If this were a more liberal judge in a similar
situation, it's easy for me to see the mainstream
media and Fox mentioning the story constantly
for days on end.
I would love to hear your thoughts.
On another note, I've been a member over a
year now and love what you do.
You're doing a great job.
Keep it up.
Thank you.
So we have a situation where like every week
there's a pretty major scandal during the
Trump presidency.
It was basically every other day.
But now, every week or every couple of weeks,
there's some big story we found out.
Find out something crazy that Mark Meadows
did or Ginni Thomas did or whatever.
Ginni Thomas was quite involved as a supporter
of the January 6th festivities, and the story
has basically gone away.
And I think it's just an information overload
type of thing.
It's two things.
Right wing media won't even talk about it.
And then in addition, even we on the left
and independent media, we also have so many
things to talk about that we can't keep every
story in the forefront all the time.
That's why it's good to have lots of independent
media outlets, some that specialize on legal
stories, some that specialize in whatever.
But you're completely right.
The story's kind of gone, and it may be gone
forever.
Last week, I asked about who is more dangerous
in a cult, and the cult is Trumpism, the true
believers or the false believers who go, Yeah,
yeah, yeah, the election was stolen, but they
don't really believe it, but they say it to
be part of the team.
Silver wrote in and said, David, I believe
the false believers are worse.
It's similar to my understanding of the difference
between a drug addict and a narcissist.
In other words, the drug drug addict displays
narcissistic behavior but is either unaware
or does so to get a fix.
The narcissist likewise knows they're manipulative,
manipulative behavior pattern, but they don't
care.
It is definitely a difficult question, but
I believe of the two that the one who knows
their actions could possibly be the worse
of the two is is the worse one.
So if I understand correctly, what Silver
is saying is the false believers don't even
believe this stuff, but still repeat it, knowing
that its effect could be destructive and that
thus they are worse.
Whereas the true believer in the case of the
Big Lie thinks no, the election was really
stolen.
So that's something we have to fix and therefore
they are less pernicious.
I could be convinced of that.
There's def.
There's definitely some logic to that.
Yeah.
Now that makes some sense.
Canadian Paul wrote in about the Republican
recently suggesting foresee be killed by firing
squad writing in stochastic force by firing
squad.
Sir, I would like to add another consideration
to your coverage of the, uh, p you y aso I
don't know what that acronym is.
John Bennett and his suggestion that Dr. Fauci
should face a firing squad.
I believe this to be the least common form
of execution today, but it was used quite
intentionally.
Of the 74 million Republican Trump voters,
how many have a gas chamber in their basement,
an electric chair in their living room, or
the chemistry background to administer a lethal
injection?
Now how many have a gun?
Keep up the great work.
I think the point that Canadian Paul is talking
about here is if you want to get 40 killed
and you go, forces should be sent to the electric
chair.
Most Trumpists don't have an electric chair
in their basement.
Maybe some do, but most don't.
They don't have the means to do the thing
that's being suggested.
But many Trumpists have a gun.
And that's why he said firing squad.
That Canadian Paul may be on to something.
It may not have been an accident that the
term firing squad was used, Steve wrote in
about the pandemic, and Steve says, Do you
really think states are honestly reporting
COVID cases?
I don't for 1/2 think the reports are honest
from all states, not even close.
So the answer is no.
But there's two parts to this.
One, are there states that are deliberately
hiding COVID cases at this point?
Maybe.
I mean, listen, probably there's 50 states
there's you could probably find an example
of some official somewhere who is limiting
the higher numbers from being published.
It's probably true.
The bigger issue is now a lot of people who
have symptoms don't even get tested.
So they just don't show up in the numbers.
And a lot of people who do a home test and
test positive never report it.
And so, of course, the numbers are lower.
I'm still hearing some reports that say the
real case numbers are 2 to 3 times higher
than what is being reported.
But it's not necessarily.
Really because the numbers are being lied
about.
It's people are testing at home or not testing,
and none of that ever makes it into the case
numbers.
Next, the email is about Dan Bongino and my
pronunciation.
Dan Bongino, you disappointed me.
Hi, David.
I love your show.
Keep up the great work.
Started watching your show a few months ago
because you're fair and you explain things
with data.
You disappointed me when you pronounced Dan
von Gino's name incorrectly.
The AI is pronounced as a long E and not an
AI Bongino.
I only bring this up because you go on all
the people that pronounced the new Supreme
Court nominees name incorrectly, which is
great, and I agree with you 100%.
To paraphrase, you said something like, Come
on, guys, get the name right.
You actually said maybe they're doing it on
purpose.
Maybe they don't know how to pronounce it.
You did the exact same thing with Dan Bongino.
So, David, were you making fun of Dan's name
or did you really not know how to pronounce
it?
I'm sure a lot in the audience, as I do await
your answer.
Keep up the great work.
What do you guys think?
You guys think I know it's not pronounced
Bon Gino.
You think I know it's not pronounced, Tulsi
Gabbard.
You think I know it's not pronounced?
Jimmy Dorsey.
Let me know.
I think the answer will become very evident,
Philip wrote in a quick correction at this.
I love this.
I love being corrected on this stuff.
We talked about the betting odds for candidates.
You can go on the website, predict it, and
you can bet money's who will be the Republican
nominee.
You can bet on anything you want.
And Philip wrote in and said, David, you described
it as $0.70 of every dollar bet to describe
the process of betting using the predicted
prediction markets.
In reality, the prices are the cost of a contract
that settles at either a dollar or nothing,
not the amount of every dollar bet on that
market.
It's the cost of a contract, not the volume.
Might be pedantic, but I know David values
accuracy.
No, I appreciate that.
When you go on to predict it, it'll say, for
example, $0.70 next to Donald Trump.
I wrongly said that means $0.70. 70% of the
dollars bet are being bet on Trump being the
nominee.
That's wrong.
But I think if I understand correctly, you
have to bet $0.70 to end up making a dollar
because it's relatively likely that it will
be Trump, whereas on a longshot candidate,
you might only have to bet $0.05 to make a
dollar if you're right.
I think that that's the correct way.
I'm not a big betting guy, but I appreciate
the correction.
Okay.
Lastly, and guys, this is just an instructive
thing on things I can't do.
Sunday night own wrote to me and said, Hey,
David, I'm late on a part that's due for my
paper.
It's a persuasive essay.
We could choose any topic.
So I chose why corporate money should be taken
out of politics.
I need counter arguments to that point.
I was wondering if you knew any to make it
easier on me.
Guys, I can't help you with your homework,
okay?
You would be surprised at how often I get
stuff like this.
You got to do your own work.
I can't.
Number one, this was due the next day.
You know, even if you thought I could help
you with your homework.
If you email me Sunday night for Monday homework,
I obviously can't help you.
Number two, I don't have the ability or wherewithal
and resources to respond to the emails that
I got.
And number three, do your own work.
And please, this is a very important life
lesson.
Do your own work, I'm begging you.
All right.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at join Pacman dot com.
You'll get instant access.
It'll be a beautiful thing.
You can use the coupon code.
Obama Now remember that.
Obama.
Speaker 3: Obama Now.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you can use that as a coupon
code to get a discount when you sign up and
we'll see you on the bonus show.